[Applause]
[Music]
if we were to ask you about Sweden I'm
sure many of you would automatically
think of the environment the fight
against global warming or even Animal
Welfare after all we are talking about a
country where more than 10 of the
population is vegan or vegetarian and
yes of course it is also Greta tunberg's
Homeland so many of you may think of
Sweden as something as a Bastion of
anti-pollution anti-dirty industry
anti-exploration and anti-natural
resources and the rejection of
capitalist life in general the land of
campaigns for a different and better
world that leaves behind materialism and
the excesses of humanity well at least
this is what many people think for
others on the other hand Sweden is
probably the country that promotes the
most radical social democracy and
anti-development campaigns others may
also think of immigration or waves of
violence
[Music]
be nice at me Sweden is usually a
country that almost never leaves anyone
indifferent at least almost no one but
beyond politics this country has other
very different facts for example what
would you think if I told you that
Sweden is also one of the great mining
powers of Europe yes amazing power and
while that's not exactly the world's
most eco-friendly thing it is 100 True
of course having said that the question
is why on Earth are the guys at
visualpolitik talking about mining in
Sweden is it really that relevant well
yes the truth is that it is it is much
more important than we might think at
first glance take a look at this 12th of
January 2022 Sweden finds Europe's
largest deposit of rare earth metals
which could become more important than
oil and gas so there you have it we are
talking about huge deposits of 1 million
tons of rare earth oxides which in
addition to others discovered in Finland
Greece and yes also in Spain
foreign
mineral elements with unique magnetic
luminescent and electrochemical
properties are known as rare Earth
elements these include lanthanum or
neodymium which are used among other
things to manufacture cars there is also
yetrium which is essential for producing
such diverse things as semiconductors
and some Pharmaceuticals
and some may be wondering but then why
talk specifically about Sweden when
there are deposits of these same
minerals in other countries well not
only because this newly discovered
deposit of rare Earths is the largest in
Europe but also for other reasons not
strictly related to mining so without
giving any more spoilers are you ready
let's get into it but first let me ask
you another one have you ever heard of
ransomware no it's not a heavy metal
band or anything like that look imagine
that you are surfing the internet and
without really knowing why you end up on
a website of a supposed antivirus
software the thing is that you download
the software to test it and that's it
you've just installed a fake antivirus
that has access to all of your data and
now they are going to encrypt that data
in exchange for a ransom or worse they
are going to steal it and sell them to a
third party if you think this can't
happen to you you may be right but be
very careful because it may happen to
your parents since the elderly are the
target audience of lots of ransomware so
what can we do always be very careful
keep your system updated and use
nordvpn's threat protection to just to
be safe threat protection works in the
background even when your device isn't
connected to a VPN server and not only
that remember that when you use nordvpn
you can browse Without Borders unlocking
a whole world of content it is also
compatible with all different types of
devices Android Windows Macs Linux and
you can include up to six devices on a
single account don't wait any longer go
to nordvpn.com forward slash VPN and get
an exclusive deal for yourself and if
you change your mind no problem you can
have 30 days to try it without any
obligation and now let's get cracking
with our video
[Music]
The Rebirth of the mining muscle
mining in Sweden is not exactly a new
activity we're talking about a sector
with a long tradition that has been
evolving over some 6 000 years in fact
one of its most famous Minds The falun
mine which is no longer in operation
provided enormous quantities of copper
for almost a thousand years from right
back in the 10th Century until 1992. in
fact for many centuries Sweden had a
virtual monopoly on copper globally so
talking about Sweden and Mining also
comes as no surprise the ties between
this country and this sector have
historically been very close as a result
in fact Swedish companies have developed
some of the most advanced and cleanest
extractive Technologies in existence for
example iron ore extraction in Sweden
generates only one-third to one quarter
of the environmental impact that it has
in other less developed countries
[Music]
the fact is that Sweden currently has 12
major mines in operation particularly in
the northern half of the country all of
them are dedicated to the exploitation
of metals we are talking mainly about
iron lead zinc Gold Silver and copper in
fact Sweden has been the main supplier
of iron in Europe since the 18th century
and currently produces wait for it more
than 90 percent of all the iron produced
in the European Union a third of the
lead and zinc and a tent of the gold
silver and copper
and take note because this may clash
with the preconceived idea that many
people have of Sweden and also with the
fact that this sector is currently one
of the most targeted by environmental
groups as well as those factions of the
left that have exchanged the proletarian
Revolution for the climate change cause
the truth is that in this country they
take mining so seriously that they are
even going to move an entire city so
that one of their large mines can
continue to operate Swedish mining towns
sinking into the ground to be relocated
building by building we are talking
about karuna the same location where the
large deposit of rare Earths mentioned
at the beginning of this video was
discovered
but this anecdote aside the truth is
that with the change in the production
model the energy transition and the new
Mobility promoted by governments around
the world Swedish mining could be on the
verge of experiencing a golden era once
again and keep in mind this is not only
about the rare Earths we have mentioned
previously in recent years large
deposits of many other resources have
also been discovered that are absolutely
strategic for the future especially if
the goal of zero carbon emissions by
2050 is to be met do you want an example
well take a look at this
25th of January 2022 United lithium
discovers two new lithium-rich
pigmentites at Berg by project Sweden
with drilling ongoing between the rear
Earth deposit discovered in karuna and
this Berkeley lithium deposit Sweden
could become one of the most
strategically important countries in all
of Europe by far
for those of you who are not very
familiar with the subject these raw
materials rare Earths and lithium are
essential for the manufacturing things
like electric cars wind turbines and a
large number of electronic devices so
much so that many experts consider
they're more important in the long term
than gas or oil producing a three
megawatt wind turbine requires 335 tons
of steel 4.7 tons of copper 1200 tons of
concrete three tons of aluminum two tons
of rare Earth elements as well as zinc
which is really illustrative of the
volume of raw materials we need for the
green transition maros shevchovic vice
president of European commission for
inter-institutional relations so now you
can see that we know that Sweden is a
country very rich in virtually all of
these resources is Europe's largest
producer of iron which is the main raw
material used to produce steel is a
major producer of copper and zinc and
now it could also become a major
producer of rare Earths and lithium in
other words the Swedish subsoil contains
almost all the raw materials that are
indispensable for technological
development and energy transition but
it's not just a question of Economics it
is also a question of security it's not
just that Sweden could be another
producer but according to the data from
the European commission itself currently
around 98 of the rare Earths that the
European Union consumes come from a
single country do you know which one
exactly if the People's Republic of
China
[Music]
[Applause]
we have covered this in a past video
here on visualpolitik and of course if
one thing has become clear in recent
times is that relying too much on one
country for the supply of Key Resources
can have dire consequences even more so
if that country is a dictatorship and a
regime that is increasingly hostile to
the West as is the case with Xi Jinping
company so it's no joke Sweden could be
a safe Escape Route to reduce this huge
dependence and prevent things like this
from happening in Europe
22nd of September 2010 amid tension
China blocks vital exports to Japan
Chinese Customs officials are haunting
shipments to Japan of so-called Rare
Earth elements preventing them from
being loaded aboard ships at Chinese
pulse
29th of May 2019 China is ready to use
rare Earths to strike back in a trade
war with the United States Chinese
newspapers warned on Wednesday so it's
better to try not to rely solely on
Chinese suppliers even though China has
approximately half of all proven
reserves of rare Earths in the world in
fact that makes this a big issue
the problem is that according to the
estimates of the European Union Itself
by 2030 the demand for rare Earths will
increase five-fold worldwide electric
cars smartphones tablets technology
networks wind turbines the demand is
going to be phenomenal and we are
talking about a time frame of under
seven years so if we don't want Xi
Jinping to have the upper hand we need
Alternatives and that's where Sweden
comes in and also other countries like
Finland of course certainly the
bureaucrats in Brussels seem to be
starting to be concerned about this
issue EU to introduce targets for raw
materials self-sufficiency in its
critical raw materials act the
commission will be looking beyond the
classic rare Earth's Scandium type thing
to focus also on other materials that
are needed for the green transition
handily said and clearly copper is going
to be necessary for electrification of
the global economy of course don't think
that this generates much peace of mind
in this sector they aren't dreading
Brussels appetite for regulation take a
look at this at the moment is it a
priority to increase regulation no I
think it's a priority to have successful
projects delivering what you need as an
a matter of urgency Mark ruckoviedis
president of Lobby group Euro mines
regarding the future critical raw
materials act be that as it may all
indications are that Sweden will
experience a mining Renaissance in the
coming years and this could be great
news for the whole of Europe of course
for that to be possible we have to join
the dots so far we have two sides the
available resources and the mining
companies wanting to extract them but we
are missing the third Stockholm being on
board
during the last few years the social
democratic government has not been
particularly friendly to this industry
bureaucratic processes dragged on and
exploration and exploitation licenses
suffered enormous delays in fact
according to the international ranking
of Canada's Fraser institutes between
2016 and 2021 Sweden has moved from 8th
Place to 36th place and attractiveness
for mining Investments of course as many
of you will know it's something we've
covered in our patreon newsletter
October 2022 so a change of political
color in the country this new Swedish
prime minister the conservative Ulf
criterson has been crystal clear on the
issue his possession well that he wants
Sweden to become a mining Nation again
so now this new government seems to want
to make it easier for many companies to
grab the picks and shovel and get to
work they even want to boost investment
by the state-owned mining company lkab
which is the largest iron ore producer
in all of Europe of course since we are
talking about Sweden the new government
has another Ace up its sleeve that is
bound to raise a few eyebrows they want
nothing less than to strengthen their
role and become a kind of nuclear power
for civilians let's check this out
foreign
3.0
Sweden one of the greenest countries par
Excellence could become one of the major
European nuclear Powers we are talking
about civil nuclear power of course in
Stockholm as far as we know nuclear
weapons have not yet been considered but
energy from atoms as one of the keys to
the future is definitely being
considered and it seems that they are
serious in fact the key proposition of
the new government would be to replace
the concept of 100 renewable energies
with 100 fossil free energies this means
bringing nuclear production into the
equation and the truth is that if you
think about it for a moment it makes all
the sense in the world
Sweden's bet will be on smr's small
modular reactors to this end they are
willing to modify the current
legislation and provide Public Credit
guarantees that until now were only
available for renewable energies and not
only that they even want to prohibit by
law that any future government tries to
speed up the decommissioning of nuclear
reactors arbitrarily in other words they
want to Shield investments in this type
of energy in fact all this has been
embodied in an agreement the Tito
agreement an agreement that made it
possible to form a government and which
was reached between the parties of the
right wing block the Christian democrats
the Liberals the moderate party and the
Sweden Democrats
that's right a four-party political
agreement that underpins nuclear power
and don't forget that we are talking
about Sweden it's quite an about turn
this agreement also contains a
commitment to developing the necessary
legislation to implement small modular
reactors in the country reactors that
are considered the future of civil
nuclear power
[Music]
this will include ending the limit
imposed by Swedish law of a maximum of
10 nuclear reactors operating at the
same time allowing construction at new
locations other than existing plants and
simplifying the permitting process to
give you an idea of what this means
while Sweden currently has six reactors
that provide around 31 of its energy the
nuclear slice of Sweden's Future Energy
Mix could be closer to 50
this basically means that nuclear power
could become the base load power in the
Scandinavian country with Renewables
which are not regular as Peak demand
support
[Music]
at the moment two companies have already
signed a memorandum of understanding to
plan the deployment of a general
electric hitachi's future Japanese bwrx
300 modular reactor which would put
Sweden at the Forefront of new energy in
Europe smrs can provide both industry
and municipalities with predictable and
fossil-free electricity heat and
hydrogen together with new wind power
new nuclear will be a crucial piece of
the climate transition puzzle Laurent
lavogue head of Fulton's new build
feasibility study so you see the swedes
want to play again the big question or
rather the two big questions are will
they do it and will they be allowed to
well at the moment all we know is that
the study to build Smalls module
reactors in Sweden will be completed by
the end of 2023 or early 2024 and as
always we'll be keeping a close eye on
everything that happens in this
Scandinavian country but in the meantime
the questions are over to all of you
well Sweden succeed in becoming the
leading country for the European energy
transition thanks to its mining industry
will it be able to carry out its
ambitious nuclear plans in the long term
leave us your answers Below in the
comments and remember if you like this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik so you don't miss any of
our latest updates and remember that you
can actively support us by joining our
community on patreon we'll leave you a
link in the description once again thank
you for watching all the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]